merci,
une production épique comme la
série Indiana Jones est vraiment une collaboration
et une grande partie de cela est la
musique de Johnny Williams qui a
donné tant de détails à chaque
moment à couper le souffle et a lié tous
ces films ensemble et a donné à ces
films une identité musicale.
thème qu'en trois notes vous
reconnaîtrez il a juste cette
signature dans ce qu'il fait La
musique de John
en parallèle
c'est tout simplement incroyable à quel point
les thèmes que John
crée pour chaque élément du film que
j'ai eu la chance d'être sont originaux et puissants
associé aux films sur une
période de temps assez longue pour, avec chaque film,
ajouter davantage à la collection de matériel musical,
non, si John faisait tout le film, j'ai
seulement prié au début, il a dit que j'écrirais
quelques thèmes et ensuite il pourrait simplement "
J'arrête pas d'écrire toute la musique du film
bon après-midi à tous merci d'
être venus cet après-midi
la chose dont je ne m'en remets jamais, d'accord,
c'est la façon dont vous êtes assis sur une scène de notation et
Sean lève son bâton
étranger
[Musique]
allez-y oh mon Dieu
[Applaudissements]
Gore nous a réveillés,
notre orchestre est
étranger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]